good morning and thank you so much for
coming I would also like to say good
morning and I wish you were here to all
of those who are here with us in spirit
but just physically couldn't make it to
New Haven I want you to know if this is
being filmed and and you're listening
that we're remembering you fondly we
hold you tightly in our hearts and we
wish you were here
you're really missed yesterday through
yesterday our panels dealt with the
decision to go co-educational and its
historical context through Julia PIM
stirs wonderful movie and the results of
the survey we got a glimpse of what it
was like to be here in 1969 today we're
going to plunge more fully into that
with a panel of six of us two from each
class and our moderator is Ann Perkins
and was a trailblazer herself she
entered Yale and 1977 a momentous year
it turned out for Co education across
the pond she received her BA and was a
trailblazer in that she was the first
woman editor-in-chief of the Yale Daily
News
[Applause]
after Yale and won the prestigious
rhodes scholarship to Oxford in 1977 it
took an act of Parliament to change the
Yale trust to allow women to attend and
as Rhodes Scholars and read modern
history at Valley Oak College and baliya
College talk about male tradition belial
College had been single sex from 1282
until 1977 but back in the 1200 s it was
a woman who originally funded Balio
college after after receiving her after
reading modern history at Bailey oh and
return and got a master's in public
administration from Harvard University
she then taught and worked in
educational policy until at the age of
52 she had what I like to think of as a
midlife epiphany and decided to get a
PhD she juggled working while pursuing a
PhD in higher education at the
University of Massachusetts a paper
which she had to write for a retired
course eventually led to this wonderful
book Yale needs women and I love the
title it's just fantastic
and interviewed many many of us and I
spoke to many of them who many of us who
were interviewed by her that everyone
was delighted with the process and very
pleased with the results it's with great
pleasure that I introduced and Perkins
Pam is very kind and calling my late
night life PhD an epiphany really it was
one of those better late than never
moments and I did get my PhD and it's
very odd for people to call me dr.
Perkins so it is such an honor to be
here this weekend with all of you the
first women of Yale College the New York
Times called do the female versions of
Nietzsche's ubermensch
whatever that means super women but what
was it like really to be a woman student
at Yale during those tumultuous early
years of co-education and the the goal
we're trying to accomplish here today is
perhaps to give you a chance to listen
and learn from other women as you might
not have been able to do when you were a
student here I this is a different type
of session from the ones before because
in addition in addition to the experts
up here every single woman sitting in
the chairs out there who started at Yale
is an expert on this topic
and so we're gonna organize this a
little differently but before I get to
that gameplan I just want to begin by
introducing our panelists as Pam said
you know you've heard this weekend on
topics from before you got here - sorry
Billy - well after you arrived but our
goal here today is to go narrower and
deeper for years only 1969 to 1973 and
so the brief intro BIOS that the
panelists and I put together emphasize
that part of their life you can think of
it as a two or three sentence glimpse at
who they were when they came to Yale and
one or two of the things that they did
so I invite you to listen to these BIOS
four ways that they intersect with your
own ways that they offer perspectives
that you did not have when you were at
Yale and also four perspectives and
experiences that are not up here on this
panel
for which you might be able to provide
us some insights I'll start with the
class of 71
so Billie Tsien attended a public high
school in New Jersey and spent her first
two years of college at Pembroke the
former and now vanished Women's College
of Brown University Billie was in
Pearson I was Whaley here to cheer for
that and majored in fine art one of her
unforgettable Yale memories was the
December 1969 draft lottery and the
sound of the lottery numbers echoing
through the Pearson courtyard over
speakers that students had set up for
the purpose some of you may remember
that as well Kathy Murphy also class of
71 came to Yale as a junior after
spending her first two years of college
at Mount Holyoke she grew up in Fremont
Nebraska
population 18,000 is there really
someone else from Fremont here she was
the first in her family to go to college
at Yale Kathy was in Calhoun grace
hopper where she worked as a master's
aide she majored in study of the city
and met her husband a fellow hooni
working the Calhoun hot line over made a
class of 72
Gerald camp arrived at Yale is a
sophomore after starting college at the
University of Rochester which I think
I'm right in saying you despised is that
correct for her first three years of
high school Jarrell attended Booker T
Washington in Atlanta Georgia's first
public high school opened to
african-americans for her last two years
she attended Scarsdale high school in
New York Jarrell was active in the BSA
why and was a member of the yield Lea
Club she majored in afro-american
studies with a concentration in
political science Cahill K came to Yale
from a large public high school in West
Hartford she spent her freshman year at
Wellesley and arrived at Yale as a
sophomore at Yale Kay was in jé majored
in psychology worked at Dwight Hall
and taught ESL is a volunteer in the New
Haven Public Schools
she lived off campus for junior and
senior years including in a house that
she helped renovate in collaboration
with the Yale student Community Housing
Corporation in our class of 73 members
Joan Abramson attended a large public
high school in San Francisco and had
already been accepted at Stanford when
she heard Yale was going co-ed she sent
in her application without telling her
parents at Yale Joan was in Davenport
college and majored in philosophy and
psychology she worked as a TA for Yale
Law Professor Charlie Reich author of
the best-selling the greening of America
and last but definitely not least KY
Emmons class of 73 KY graduated from a
public high school in suburban Boston
she was in je and majored in psychology
and drama she devoted much of her time
at Yale to theatre first acting then
writing plays one of which Murgatroyd
was staged in New York City during the
strike her freshman year KY became a
more ardent feminist and as a result
joined a group that helped New Haven
women obtain abortions in New York
because they were still illegal here in
Connecticut so that's our panel and
here's our game plan you know we all
know the drill of a typical panel the
experts speak the audience sits and
listens and then at the very end the
audience can ask questions and woe
betide he/she who stands up and tries to
make a statement instead of a question
because you'll get the big eye roll from
the moderator we're gonna change those
rules in two ways one is for each
question I'm going to start with one or
two or maybe even three of the panelists
but then I'm going to come out to you as
the audience so you have a chance to
speak to that topic before we move on to
the next and then while you're more than
welcome to ask questions you are also
welcome if you want to share your own
experience on the question 2 app and
answer it directly and speak to that
experience so that's the good part
here's the frustrating part there are
300 stories in this room of what it was
like to be a first woman
Yale and every single one of those
stories deserves to be heard and honored
in its entirety and we have at this
point 75 minutes to do so mission kind
of impossible but there are two things
that we can do together this morning one
is for every woman that chooses to speak
we can give her the gift of being heard
and of being seen and the other is we
can think of this as the start of a
conversation a conversation that I hope
that all of you will continue not just
today but onward after this weekend
because it's a really important
conversation to hold and the experts in
the entire world on this conversation
are you we're gonna try to back to
mission impossible
we're gonna try to include as many
voices as possible and cover a wide
range of topics we came up with 12
questions I cut them to 9:00 last night
don't even know if we're gonna get to
all nine I'm gonna try to spend about 10
minutes per question and so we'll see
how that goes so let's begin the first
topic is identity students arrived at
Yale in 1969 with many identities what
was your hometown your religion your
gender your race and ethnicity your
sexuality were you the smart girl in
class the athlete and Billy I'm gonna
start with you what identity was most
salient to you when you came to Yale and
why I think when I came to Yale I had no
particular identity except that I knew
that I wanted in some way or another to
be different and obviously I was
different however I couldn't figure out
how and coming from a family of
engineers and scientists and this sort
of whole Chinese pressure of trying to
do the same thing I decided that what I
would do it'd be a major in art but
the interesting thing was I came from
Pembroke and I just remember thinking
this is not the place for me because
every weekend women would dress up in
dresses and wear corsages and go to
football games and I thought I can't be
here so when I came to Yale the thing
that was amazing for me was that there
were more different kinds of people
doing more odd things in their own
little ways than I could have ever
perceived when I was at Pembroke at that
time and that for me was incredibly
freeing and it's I think what that
taught me was I didn't know how to get
there and I didn't really know how I was
going to become different in the way
that I wanted to but people are starting
to figure that out while they were here
and that's I think how I felt that I
learned something about my identity
although I didn't know the answer what
when I was here thank you and I should
note that Billy avoided one thing which
is because I'm trying to keep track of
time I have a lovely I'm sorry that was
so sexist I have a young timekeeper in
the back row who's going to do this for
me if anyone hits two minutes and so
just just to let you know but Billy
avoided the yellow card don't you want
to jump in and give us the front of the
perspective as a freshmen woman which is
almost as obnoxious as asking you the
opinion of a woman but yeah yeah it's
I'm a fifth generation San Franciscan
and for me that really was my identity
and I had never thought about living on
the East Coast or anything like that I
just was very happy and involved in
California both in in nature a lot of
hiking and you know loved the Sierras
and I wrote poetry and and I was in my
own kind of world but a very social
justice oriented and I was the youth
representative of the Human Rights
Commission when I was in high school so
in Grace Cathedral where we met it was
amazing so anyway wouldn't when I my dad
really wanted me to go to Stanford
because he'd gone there I was admitted
to Stanford everyone was happy I ain't
one to go I was like I want to go
somewhere no one knows me I want to go
somewhere where I can find out who I am
without everybody knowing already who I
am and I I didn't when I when I told my
parents at dinner that I was going to
Yale they were furious
my dad was he wouldn't talk to me for a
day it was really upset and any rate he
got used to it but he would do things
like do you know what their song is
bula-bula
and I said that's not true so so they
dropped me off at the San Francisco
Airport I'm with my green footlocker I
had had it camp you know I fir here and
I get on the plane I get off at JFK in
the TWA terminal and I look at this
sarin in building and I am like blown
away you know I've never seen anything
like that so then I get the flag down
the Connecticut limousine and they put
my footlocker on the on the top of the
van and drive me here and it dropped me
right outside the old campus you know
dragged across from the green and at the
gate there and I'm there with my
footlocker thinking how the hell am I
gonna get this thing anywhere so I walk
I leave it there and I walk I walk into
the old campus and flag down a couple of
guys who they carried it up to the
entryway six and the of course the top
floor or something and and I meet my
roommates and we walk over to Davenport
for the welcome speech and of course the
Welcome song I'm telling I'm just gonna
warn you you got the yellow card so if
you wrap it up disappear when I'm not
gonna tell you that story because oh you
got to make sure to ask her after is
important is this because this is
important my my only mentor and advisor
that I was assigned was Rulon wells who
was in Davenport I don't know if
anyone's ever met him he was a
classicist and I don't think he'd ever
seen a woman
student before ever in his life and so
he walks in and he says now what would
you like to major him and I said
forestry and Rulon Wells looks at me and
says you can't major in forestry the
gantt there is no forestry classes I
said what sage Hall is famous for
forestry I wanted to be a forest ranger
in one of those little Ranger houses you
know where you could write poetry and
and I and he looked at me like I was an
alien and it was just like flabbergasted
and when I left he was so happy that he
never had to see me again and then I
wanted to say that I was asked so often
I know but it'll be fast for the woman's
point of view that in my classics class
as a freshman I I finally started
enjoying it so I would say oh well the
woman's point of view of Odysseus is you
know when he was tied to the mast and
they said the sirens were luring him to
his death no I said the sirens were
simply singing they were in the water
they were friends they were singing they
were happy I said I said I said listen I
said you know it's not our fault he
wanted to jump in
[Applause]
alright anyone in the audience who wants
to speak to this who can top that story
because I bet you can't who wants to
speak to this question of identity and
and you know when I'm thinking about it
I'm curious were there aspects of your
identity that we're in conflict that you
couldn't be both at the same time or
were there aspects that changed while
you were here at Yale yeah Carol oh and
if you could start by seeing your name
and your class just so everyone can know
you if they don't already yeah hi I'm
Carol storey Johnson class of 1973 and
I'm gonna put a plug in if you haven't
read the book ill needs women you need
to read it it's a really terrific
terrific thanks and peace so real
quickly so here I am an african-american
woman
class of 1973 and I come and I have a
lot of interesting thoughts about
whether or not I'm identifying with
women or with the african-american
community and actually early on and I'm
sure Jarrell is gonna speak to some of
this so Jarrell I you know certainly
gonna corroborate some of our mutual
story but connected with the Black
Student Alliance at Yale and it was
actually a kind of a haven for folks
like me who were looking for identity
pieces and it was enormous ly important
and I think it actually kind of
protected me in certain ways from some
of the other things that many of the
other women in on campus were going
through and talks a lot in her book
about the sexual harassment pieces that
went on here at Yale and I was actually
curious from the panel whether or not
folks on the piano we're aware of all of
that that was going on especially
numbers that's question number seven
yeah thanks so much Carol anyone else
who wants to speak to the identity
question before we move on you see right
there
Meredith right 71 my high school sort of
social life revolved around something
particularly odd which was Balkan or
international folk dancing and are you
gonna give us her performance please
but within a month of arriving as a
transfer student there was a poster up
advertising for auditions for the Yale
Slavic chorus and I knew I had found my
home that's great thanks so much okay
we're gonna move on to the next
questions and I'm sorry if that's one
you wanted to talk to please continue to
speak to one another about it this one's
on engagement we're going to go a little
broader and Kay I'm gonna start with you
what was your this is an impossible
question but I I don't have to answer it
what was your greatest passion when you
were at Yale what mattered most to you
and why I would say what mattered to me
was really being involved in the
community and engagement and service
along with a handful of other women
before
Yale officially started in the fall we
spent the summer working for Dwight Hall
and I taught art and ESL with children
on Grand Avenue who were mostly Puerto
Rican I loved using my Spanish I loved
the children and actually it was pivotal
in my career my very first job after
graduating from Yale was opening the
first bilingual daycare center the brain
can center in New Haven and I was hired
by Hunta for whom I had worked before I
ever started here I look back with
amazement that at 21 I thought I could
get funding for a daycare center hire
the bilingual local teachers put in the
tiny toilets
and run the connection to the main water
line where it turned out we were going
through some of the tombs of the
founders of the church where we were but
we diverted I also it was alluded to
along with a group of six others we
renovated a house where a child had
acquired lead paint poisoning and
stripped the lead paint then we lived in
the house ourselves when it wasn't ready
on time
Yale let us live in an office building
on Ashman Street
Judy Burkham will remember that she was
part of that group of seven and then in
my senior year I taught I arranged all
my classes and taught ESL as a volunteer
in the New Haven Public Schools and then
I lived off campus junior year in senior
year and I was hired than to be a
teacher and had a 35-year career ending
it as a central office administrator in
charge of a number of programs and then
I retired several years ago looking back
I think all of this passion for working
in the community is admirable and it's
something we would like to see perhaps
more of today but I also think in
reflecting about it that it's
interesting that I was so unaware that I
was in a place of special privilege and
opportunity to come to Yale and not be
able to wait to get away is just odd and
I think the the chance to savor all the
academics that were being offered all
the enrichment all the culture and
having your meals prepared for you in a
beautiful setting I find it kind of
amusing and interesting but it's
probably also a sign of the times that
we were so passionate about being
helping other people thanks Kay kai you
want to speak to that one too about
engagement okay my time at Yale was sort
of bifurcated by a semester off I'd uh
the second part of my sophomore year I
came to Yale very passionate about
theater I'd been acting and eventually I
would begin writing plays but my
interest in that kind of waned about
halfway through my time here I applied
for the five-year BA I don't know if
anybody here ended up going on that
program and oh and and God accepted to
teach English in the Marshall Islands
where I was going to be have to learn
marshalese and they asked me whether I
wanted to be on one of the big islands
or one of the outer act holes so this
happened and oh and by the way the
interview for that was there were as I
recall there was a long table with 12
people and you had to find your own job
and one of the psychiatrist's on the
interviewing committee said how would
you deal with the situation if you were
on the beach in the Marshall Islands and
someone took you had taken off all your
clothes and you then you went swimming
and when you came out there were no
clothes there for you I I just thought
it was really I mean well we all
understand the context of this Wow and I
can't recall how I answered but I did
but Joan to answer it for you she would
have had some so but at the same time
one of the people in the drama school
that I'd been acting with one of the
directors had asked me if I wanted to be
in this in the spring semester of my
sophomore year in a movie on the Costa
Brava and he had written this part for
me and so if I did if I went to the
movie I couldn't go to the five-year ba
and vice versa so it was really a very
difficult decision at the time but I
thought well going to the Marshall
Islands wasn't really within something I
had imagined and it didn't seem like it
was leading to a career path and so
so I ended up deciding to go and be in
the movie in the Costa Brava however he
never got his funding and so I ended up
you know being out of school for the
sophomore sophomore year spring semester
sophomore year which was actually really
good and it was very clarifying and when
I came back to Yale this is all about
engagement I was for the latter two
years I was very understanding less you
know you got the yellow card so maybe
give us one more quick story so we can
yeah I was very engaged in psychology
and community psychology in particular
and so I sort of and ended up graduating
with both a drama degree Oh theatre
degree and a psychology degree and then
that was a huge choice but we won't go
there yet thanks so much
anyone in the audience what was your
passionate yeah what did you care most
about got Mike coming right to you hi
I'm Dalia Rudovsky
class of 73 Branford and I came to Yale
with the identity of being a student
radical somehow from my high school days
I had organized our anti-war Club at my
high school in Newton Massachusetts and
Yale did not disappoint within the first
month I think we were on a hunger strike
I don't know if you remember the
moratorium and I remember sitting in
front of Vanderbilt on the third or
fourth day of this hunger strike very
weak we were on a juice juice fast and
that was one of my first memories and
then soon thereafter mrs. Williams who
was a dining hall worker was fired for
throwing some orange juice at a
supervisor who had ordered her around
and there was SDS on campus organized
reinstate mrs. Williams campaign and
then the Panthers came to town and you
know from there we never had a spring
semester so
at the same time I had some great
literature courses which were a total
the other side of the life so you know
wonderful in that way and I also want to
thank and for putting it all together so
we can see how our individual
experiences were reflected in the
zeitgeist thanks Dahlia any other anyone
else would I inject a little levity here
I can't really say it was a passion but
I really wanted to be on Jeopardy and
you repeat that I'm not sure everyone
heard I really wanted to be on Jeopardy
oh I trained I had some I was in
Branford I've got a website by the way
and I have free guy friends and I would
play home jeopardy in their room many
times a week and I figured that I had a
pretty good chance of getting on because
I had this gimmick which was I was in
the first class of women at Yale so
indeed I went down to New York and I
tried out and they called me back
I brought three outfits because they
they filmed them all seriatim I won the
first day I did not bet enough money the
second day on double jeopardy no
jeopardy so I lost and I emerged with
1820 dollars
the Encyclopedia Americana and home game
[Applause]
I don't know if you all know this Brenda
juban who was on the panel yesterday
when she got appointed as the first
woman Dean of a residential college she
got called up by the head of what's my
line I don't know if you remember that
and she went on as the first and and
they didn't get what no one could guess
what she was okay one more and then
we'll right there with the red shirt
Laura hansman 73 je following up on your
story I had gotten into the University
of Santa Cruz and Reed College and
Oregon and I wasn't going to come to
Yale and my parents were furious and
made me come to Yale and I think about
how different my life would have been if
I had gone to those two other schools
and I followed on in I proposed of the
Black Panthers I did get arrested three
weeks into our freshman year for sitting
in at a welfare Center they were cutting
off the benefits of welfare moms or
reducing them and I there came a moment
when they said those of you who want to
get arrested stay those who don't leave
and all the jelly's but me and one other
Gwen I don't know if you're here got
arrested and I was 17 so the Dean of je
had to be my guardian and to say that
they were wondering why did we get these
women at Yale I think went through his
mind thank you
[Applause]
so I when I interviewed many of you for
my research a topic that came up again
and again is this topic of friendship so
I'm going to switch to that and Jarrell
I want to start with you how did you
meet your closest friends at Yale and
what did you have in common with them
and and how are you different and I and
sort of a follow-up just to give you way
too many questions to answer it once
were you ever lonely here how did I meet
my closest friends of you as a member of
the VSA why and as an african-american
woman on campus I had the opportunity to
engage with the entire black community
that was on campus it made a difference
I just in the past two days have come to
understand what a difference it made
because it's been clearly appear to me
that many of us didn't have an easy time
establishing friendships on Yale's
campus and that made the experience much
harder within the BSA why we had the
good fortune to have some wonderful
people who made participating in that
organization a priority they generously
gave of their time and their resources
and their their physical facilities we
met we made friends by participating in
dinners in our colleges or in Berkeley
College because room 597 was the home of
Stephanie Brown and Sheila Jack then
Sheila Jackson a networking hub for the
black community on campus we had Afro
America house which gave us a place to
locate there were the protests which we
all went through together and had
experiences that we never enter
as part of our undergraduate experience
but all of it gave us opportunities to
grow and to get to know each other what
did we share in addition to our racial
identity we I think it's fair to say we
shared the sense of being part of an
experimental generation many of us
became involved in as the diversity
element in institutions which had never
had persons of color students of color
present on campus
I guess that came through most clearly
at Yale
during the Mayday proceedings when
everybody had to make a decision about
whether we were going to go home or stay
and I remember very clearly a big
discussion which was held on the campus
at the afroamerican house where it
became clear to me that many of the
students made participating in the
politics of the day a priority many of
the students felt that they were at Yale
to get a degree and didn't have time and
didn't want to run the risk of being on
campus during they day but it also
occurred to me that the black students
were the nexus between the community and
the university the community saw the
black students as representatives of
Yael Yael saw the black students as a
conduit to the community we thought we
came here to get a degree but it was a
time when the world was changing and we
wanted to be a part of that and people
made an effort to get through the
protests to get through the degree
requirements to get through all of the
psychological and emotional changes that
have
an undergraduate would go through and to
make friends in the process we were very
fortunate in the absence of a structure
at Yale for advising and counseling
there were people in the black community
who stepped in to fill those roles there
were people like Roy Bryce Laporte who
was the head of the afro-american
studies program there was Ernie Osborn
and his wife Betty who welcomed us to
their home and into his office and
became counselors there were students
who stepped up and acted as mentors and
counselors for those of us who had never
been in jail before and the people who
come to mind are Armstead Robinson whom
you heard Sam Chauncey mentioned last
night glady Chabert who was the
president of the Black Student Alliance
Yale I dad Michael Beck Narus to that
group who was the first of an entire
contingent of black men who came to Yale
from st. Augustine just one second so
and I would just add Sylvia Boone to the
list who when she finally came gave us a
female who could be a counselor so those
were our primary methods for
establishing friendships that in many
cases have survived the years thanks so
much
so Kathy you come from a very different
world and I'm curious who were your
friends and how did you meet them and
how were they like you and different
than you well I came to I came to Yale
from Mount Holyoke and one of my five
one of my four roommates there were five
of us in the suite in Calhoun one of the
four was Mary Elizabeth Kree who also
was from Nebraska and also from Mount
Holyoke there were three Nebraskans at
Mount Holyoke two of us where that Mary
and me and we left but she and I were
roommates then in Calhoun and we had
three other roommates who came from the
East Coast but the five of us became
really really quite good friends even
though we did not spend that much time
together Mary had a boyfriend in
branford my roommate Elaine was in the
radio station Witek and was always
hanging out there one of my other
roommates Polly was a Russian Studies
major and always in the carols and
sterling so it's sort of amazing but we
we became close and we're actually
getting together in three weeks to
celebrate our 70th birthdays together
but other than other than my roommates I
think the Calvin women were were got
along very well again we didn't spend
that much time together but we would
hang out in the courtyard when people
were when it was nice weather and see
each other but I think the main way that
I made friends with the men I was a as
instead of masters aid which you know in
those days before cell phones and
computers we communicated by putting
fliers under people's doors and the mass
one of the masters age job was to go up
and down the entryways and deliver the
notices about the Masters teas or the
cocktail parties or the next lecture or
whatever so I spent a lot of time going
up and down entryways and I obviously
met a lot of the men that way by
knocking on their door and handing them
flyers or invitations yeah the other way
that I met people was I played bridge
and I I don't think anybody's mentioned
that but I played a lot of bridge my
for my junior year at Yale in fact I
played so much bridge that it's amazing
that I made it through my course it's
the only all-nighter I ever pulled at
Yale was playing bridge and I wasn't
that great a bridge player but it was
very flattering to have some especially
the senior men asked me to play bridge
with them when some of them were really
very very serious and good bridge
players so anyway so I played a lot of
bridge and the other thing I did was I
hung out in the dining hall a lot that
was to me one of the best things about
being at Yale was to sit in the dining
hall with these guys who were just very
different as somebody said incredibly
different different points of view very
knowledgeable very passionate and to
just sit there and be a fly on the wall
and listen to them debate John Bolton
was in Calhoun he was part of a I know I
know but he you know he was the party of
the right guy and then he was in he was
in a suite with Ed Ferrand who was a
very big player in the Democratic Party
in Connecticut and a Lowenstein's
campaign so you had you know you had all
these points of view and people shared
the points of view without really
getting upset with each other and it was
enlightening
yeah thanks so much so friendship can
you where's my wandering mic right there
how'd you make your friends how were
they different than you or the same hi
I'm Amelia Buchanan I was in the class
of 73 and my very best friend is sitting
next to me Nancy Briggs Stein we were in
Vanderbilt Hall next door to each other
and we had some very strange roommates
she did and I did and Nancy commented
that maybe we were all accepted to Yale
because we were all so different and I
think there's something to that so Nancy
and I were very very close
I'll just tell about one roommate who
was Nancy's Jenny from Mississippi she
was the fourth daughter the youngest of
the president of the University of
Mississippi and all of her sisters had
been debutantes they'd all gone on the
grand tour in Europe and Jenny was maybe
the original hippie Trippi her mother
would send her gowns and these elegant
clothes hoping that somehow she could be
redeemed and she would pile them in the
center of the room and let them just sit
there so later on she got married had a
baby nursed her baby in class and
defiance of the administration so she
was quite something and but Nancy and I
were very very close my parents couldn't
afford to let me go home at Thanksgiving
and I got to know Nancy's whole family
her parents and her sister at
Thanksgiving and otherwise we went we
decided to leave we were encouraged to
leave by some friends that made a we
went to her house so anyway we were very
very close throughout our Yale
experience the other friendship that I
was so fortunate to have formed was with
Abe Bartlett Giamatti who later became
the president of Yale I'm just noticing
me the yellow card so I'm trying to
cover as many voices as possible so if
you want to go make it quick so he took
me under his wing and encouraged me to
be a part of the history of the Arts and
Letters program he taught in that
program
it was absolutely magnificent it made my
intellectual experience at Yale
exquisite and forever you know how later
on he became the Commissioner of
baseball I'm a baseball freak so it was
an exquisite experience
thanks so much call him
and you know and I would love if anyone
can talk about guys his friend so
because that's something I heard an
awful lot about you know in the back
there with got it
Joyce major cause the 73 Morris college
I met my group of guy friends because
there's freshman counselor had a
television and every Sunday night he
would invite his Morse college freshman
boys to watch mission impossible and
they used that as a ploy to get me to
come and visit them I think you came
with me a few times
Nancy's my roommate from all four years
and I was from the Midwest she's from
Greenwich Connecticut and she and her
dad picked me up at the airport my very
first time on the plane got off at JFK
having no idea what she looked like
anything else but the guy friends became
some of them were pre-med like I was and
we had shared some classes but every
Sunday night popcorn and mission
impossible in Harold Mancusi and Goro's
room but there's a great friendship we
lasted we sat around the table talking I
don't think we had political discussions
but we had a lot of other does well we
maybe we did did we talk politics I
don't think so we just talked all
evening I drank so much team the enamel
was starting to wear off but the guys
were just a very important part of our
lives and I know that a lot of people
had guy friends that because they were
dating somebody and then the guy friends
friends became their friends but thanks
so much so we're going to move on to a
different topic I'm sorry I see those
hands and maybe we'll have time at the
end to come back but I hope you continue
the conversation afterwards
topic that can be challenging for women
ambition
ambition so um Kathy else I'll start
with you again over here when you got to
Yale what did you hope to become when
you left here and and I really am still
focused on those four years and how your
sense of who you could be might have
changed and actually you were only here
for two years so that makes it even a
little more challenging but did your
vision of what you could be or who you
would be changed while you were at Yale
it didn't change so much while I was at
Yale it changed from the time I entered
Mount Holyoke when I thought I wanted to
be in the Foreign Service or some kind
of job where I traveled but I took
French my first year I had taken Latin
in high school I took French my first
year at Mount Holyoke and while reading
and writing was okay I couldn't speak it
because my Midwestern twang just
murdered the murdered the language and I
realized if I couldn't speak French I
probably wasn't going to have an
international career so by the time I
got to Yale I was pretty set on going to
law school and pretty set I was a study
of the city major and I think that the
night the summer of 68
you know after Martin Luther King was
assassinated and Bobby Kennedy was
assassinated and we had the riots of 68
I became much more focused on injustice
and equity and and issues that I'd not
really focused on at all before then and
I decided that I really wanted to do
something in in an urban context and I
thought law school was the way to go by
the time I finished at Yale I I had
focused my study of the city
concentration on honor banette occation
and I had spent two summers working in
the South Bronx for the city of New
York's Board of Education doing title
federal grant applications and and
things like that
and I so I went to law school I did go
to law school and I did want to
participate in the in the all the stuff
that was going on in education at that
point there was busing was relatively
new they were you know schools were
still being integrated they were trying
to figure
how to provide equal educational
opportunity but that I knew by the time
I was a junior that I wanted at least to
be a lawyer and to do something in in to
save the world again Emily what about
you
ambition is such a tricky word so and I
see students a lot and I think ambition
is much more visible now than it was
when we were in school and how you know
how to be ambitious in a kind of world
of art but for me later became
architecture it's a really big question
I mean my I understood how to be
ambitious as a engineer or as a
scientist I didn't actually understand
how to be ambitious
within the arts I know my father when he
saw a photograph of me that was
published in the town newspaper because
I was at Yale and in the first class and
I was barefoot didn't speak to me for
three months so that was definitely
trying to figure out who I could be how
it could be ambitious the thing that I
saw at Yale was that people were
ambitious and very quiet and passionate
ways so it wasn't a kind of bombastic
ambition it was an ambition and a focus
on particular issues or subjects that
was really interesting to me the other
thing that happened was I had a amazing
art teacher
who has a show now at the Yale art
galleries name is William Bailey and I
remember in a drawing class he said to
me it's really not the lines it's the
space in between the lines and so what
that said to me is that you don't have
to be ambitious within the lines you can
find that space in between and the
desire for me then was
not to go big but to go deep and I think
I learned that here at Yale not to you
ambition I'm gonna hand it to malli but
just real quick
Casey Blanchard good morning Carol my
roommate I'm over here and I always we
were talking going to Yale you could do
any I just felt like I could do anything
and that was always just easy after you
got through Yale like living in New York
I chose Yale over Harvard because I
thought there was a better chance that I
could get on the Yale Daily News can you
tell us just her name in your memory Cox
Chapman 73 but the first year when we
were supposed to heal was overwhelming I
didn't do it so sophomore year I went
into the news office with five articles
on women at Yale a two-year perspective
and said I'd like these all to be
published on the same day and they did
it and I was immediately allowed to be a
reporter well it came time to have the
elections and I had this tape in my head
from my girls boarding school that you
don't show your ambition you do your
work you do it well and people will
notice so the week before the election I
didn't go over to the Yale Daily News
office and everybody else was over there
lobbying for the position that they
wanted so of course I didn't get elected
the election was over people are
drifting away and the five guys who were
now on the masthead looked at me and
said you jerk why weren't you here this
week what were you doing not being here
what are we going to do without you on
the team and I told them the tape that I
had and they said name what you want to
do and we'll just make up a position so
they gave me the position of chief staff
writer feature editor and I presented a
feature every day for the
cheer on the front page below the fold
so really it was the men my friends who
taught me how to name what I wanted and
asked for what I wanted I'm one right
here in the third row or who'd been
raising her hand I'm Emily fine je 73
that's an amazing story and I wish I
could say that that is reflective of a
lot of other stories but I'm not sure it
is I think the elephant in the room for
me is and I think as women instill to
this day is that it's not always so cool
for women to look ambitious and we
somehow have to find a classier way to
look ambitious because if you're too
ambitious that's not necessarily
considered acceptable it's changing
obviously thankfully but it's it's we
ride a sort of fine balance that's 1/2
the times I remember it by the end of my
sophomore year if I was working on
women's abortion referral service or
women's support groups and they would
say oh what college do you go to I would
say I'm in New Haven there was a sense
of embarrassment of being part of the
you know the elite and sort of hope that
maybe they thought we were going to
Southern Connecticut instead so that
also complicated ambition but I will say
just one shout out and then I'll be done
about engagement to slash the other
issue which is music so for me I signed
up for courses write very on and within
two weeks I dropped them all I was in
sciences I felt completely isolated
overwhelmed unsupported I eventually
obviously came back to it cuz I'm a
physician but I loved music which was my
other passion and it was at Yale
symphony where it didn't matter what
your sex was if you could play a mean
horn you had friends who were men and
women and
there were lots of women in the symphony
the ratio was much better so for me my
sense of security and home and because I
didn't feel I had the support elsewhere
was in my music life at Yale for which
I'll be forever grateful
thank you so much I apologize to the
panel I'm skipping around the order a
little bit here but I'm going to go back
haven't forgotten you so returning to
romance and relationships yeah women
[Laughter]
young women adopted a variety of
approaches when it came to romantic
relationships with Yale men some dated
multiple guys some had one steady
boyfriend some wanted a boyfriend but
didn't have one some chose not to have a
Yale boyfriend at all and some dated or
wanted to date women what approach did
you take and how did that work out for
you so Joan let's uh I'm gonna give that
to you all right
yeah no no is fine I'm just thought I'd
tell you a story I've never told anybody
I fell in love my first day Yale I when
I went from Vanderbilt all over to Gavin
port to the Commons room for the welcome
thing I I saw this guy across the room
who I thought was amazing I don't know
what it was and I thought our eyes met
but I wasn't sure so so I don't know if
you guys remember but we'd go back to
our rooms most of the days in the first
weeks and there'd be a little note
pinned to the door of people who wanted
to meet us or something cause I think
the guys felt if they didn't get a
girlfriend like really fast it was over
so there was a note on my door but it
wasn't signed it was signed with
initials and so of course I I have had
way maybe as him so I didn't know his
name and I looked through the Facebook
thing and
and he wasn't in there because I don't
know he didn't send in a picture or
something anyway it turned out it was
from him and I was like I was just like
on cloud nine and we got together and I
moved out of Vanderbilt and into his
dorm on the old campus very quickly
actually and I mean I met my roommates
but I didn't really know anyone in the
entry room so so guess what happened
parents day so my parents are traveling
from San Francisco for the first time to
see Miguel and they want to meet my
roommates so I had to go over before
parents day and I knocked on every door
in the entryway
but I wasn't delivering flyers I was
trying to meet the people and said
please just pretend you know me so I had
very few friendships with women but I
had a lot of brothers and and and that
so happened that that my my boyfriend's
one of his roommates was a bridge
fanatic and I know that bridge scene
because they were there all the time
playing all night I mean it was a thing
any rate so that happened
and but I wanted it can I talk about I
want to talk about the Shirelles no
one's mentioned them
but you know you can hear Freeland
Lorna's Sorrell yeah I just have to tell
just a little story I think all of us
but I know I got a phone call or
something they contacted me and they
said please make an appointment to see
dr. Sorrell Oh doctor mrs. Sorel and I'm
like why oh well there are you know the
gynecologist and his wife is a social
worker or something I didn't do the
shirt so they wanted me to every woman
in the first class so I'm like okay so I
go over there and this was like a
interview rather than a an exam and they
said if you ever had sex and I said no
and they said we would like to prescribe
you birth control would you like an IUD
or would you prefer the pill and I said
why do I need birth control if I haven't
had sex and they said Kingman Brewster
said no pregnancies so I got a
prescription for the pill and I thought
well maybe someday I'll take it and it
did come in handy eventually so so but
what I want to say about friendships is
ironically the way I got to know more
women and this was the second year I was
in Davenport now very much it's almost
over but you can be glad to hear this
there was a survey for sophomores where
I don't know if you guys remember this
but I'll never forget it the where they
circulated a printed survey it was about
our sexual practices and it had was long
and it said have you ever and then it
listed all these words and I really
didn't know what some of them were and
so all of us is that the girls were
talking like have you ever done this and
not only did it say have you ever it
said if so how many times a week
a month I mean it was like it was
something else so at any rate that was
like one of my my real moments at Yale
thanks June Jerell do you want to speak
to this as well you can pass if you want
I'll be really short I was lucky to have
lots of male friends and most of them
were like brothers I also was lucky in
finding a really great guy in my second
year who was in the class behind me
the difficulty came when I graduated at
last the relationship worked fine while
we were on campus fabulous guy
photographer I even learned what to do
in a darkroom
I I didn't mean that he was a good
teacher you're digging a hole here but
when we graduated when I graduated and
moved to New York our lives took
different paths and the relationship
couldn't withstand the changes so we
went our separate ways but I was always
grateful for having had shared this
experience with him because it made a
difference
thanks so much anyone else want to speak
to exes right there
I'm Alexis Kozlovsky Berkeley 71 I came
to Gail with a great deal of passion and
ambition with regards to the arts I was
so excited to be here I also was
extremely eager to participate in the
sexual liberation movement I didn't
realize that so that there were pros and
cons to that and I I guess I suffered
from post-traumatic stress disorder from
some of the sexual encounters
of course PTSD listen to turn that
existed back then it took me 20 years to
write a novel about that was in part of
fictionalization of some of those
experiences and part one of the novel is
called pillow book of a Yale co-ed and
postcards here to pass out so that so
that you'll read the book I hope you'll
let me know what you think about it it
won an award for best matron novel of
the year last year it definitely has a
lot of erotic passages I had to publish
her under a pseudonym because my dad was
alive I thought it'd be horrified and
disown me but I hope you read the book
and let me know what you think thank you
thanks Alexis way way way in the very
back row back there oh I'm sorry okay
we'll do you and then back row okay
well I'll try to make it short I'm
Marsha Eckert 71 so I'm one of those
people who came in and floated okay
everybody else is passionate and had
friends and my I had a double my
roommate was a white black panther so
she kind of took off and I was wandering
around the first semester as part of a
team from TD interviewing people about
co-education and I so I was sort of on
my own and I didn't know a lot of people
so and when the Black Panther
office got busted in New Haven they
moved into my dorm room so there were
people going part of the people and I
didn't exact I mean I was really
interested but it was all part of my
sort of floating around
so when Mayday came and I think my up my
room was closed because it had been this
office I didn't know what the heck to do
I didn't I mean I hung out with guys but
I wasn't close friends with him I didn't
really know any women and I sure as hell
wasn't going home to my mother so I had
started just six weeks before dating
someone in the theater in the Yale rep
who had come over to me in the mail room
and said I saw this light in your eyes
and I thought it was a social psych
experiment on pick-up lines and I and he
said well you can stay in my apartment
and I said well my mother is very strict
I could never stay in an apartment
unless I was married he said well then
let's get married and I said okay so
that's how I ended up with a boyfriend
Wow
are used to
that story what happened
wait wait wait can you use the mic so
that everyone can hear
for those who know it was kind of like
going steady
except you know illegally and so we were
together for about three really
fascinating years and I got to meet a
lot of interesting people who are in the
Yale rep at the time like Christopher
Walken and Christopher Lloyd and and
Meryl Streep was in the Drama School and
Henry Winkler was sort of we all lived
together and so is it really interesting
weird time being an undergraduate and a
theater wife simultaneously but after
about three years we drifted apart and I
went back to being sort of normal and
then way back there I'm Liz Oliver
Davenport 71 two parts a little bit
about dealing with ambition and also
relationship to guy friends early on I
don't know there must be other people
here who got asked to go to alumni
dinners to talk or sit next to at the
various faculty homes old crusty alums
who were really upset that Yale had gone
co-ed I don't know is there anybody else
went to those dinners them yay okay so
at one of these dinners and I have no
idea how they selected who they selected
but at one of these dinners I sat next
to someone who had graduated I believe
if memory serves and that's questionable
at this point but I think it was 1903 or
1906 and he was livid and I had been Ted
Smith for two years and one of the
reasons I wanted to leave Smith was I
grew up in New York I went to a huge
public high school with 5,000 kids and
and we're so used to use your mic
[Music]
sorry yeah and there were malaria
unnatural to me being an old Laurel
school so I was looking forward to Co
education at Yale
however this guy was telling me how
unwelcome I was and assuming that
essentially I was taking the place which
he said to me flat out what did I want
to do with my life I was all I wanted to
do was get married and find a husband
and that was my ambition to come to Yale
and that and I was taking the place of
one of yells 1,000 male leaders so I
remember leaving that dinner and the
yourself that this was a very strange
perspective to plant on first-year girls
wandering around the campus
fast forward after having many male
friends in the College someone came up
to me with another classmate who had
been drafted whose number had come up
and he had dropped out for a while and
they got him and he was about to be
drafted and the thing that he was most
worried about was that they were going
to cut his hair that his hair which he
had grown and had I mean he was worried
about a lot of things but it was an
obsession and so somebody named Gus who
was going from table to table asking if
anybody knew how to cut hair which for
whatever reasons I happen to do so we
went to essentially I'm just observing
you got your yellow card so if you can
finish this story so we can then okay
someone else totally I cut this guy's
hair as he got himself drunker and
drunker preparing to go in to report to
basic training or to report to the local
and the guy who brought him over became
a close friend and then ultimately
became my husband I am married now for
going on 47 years six years I would say
there's much to find the guy from 1903
to tell him in fact I did find a husband
I'm just we have so many questions and
so little time we're gonna the question
I'm going to talk about is ask Nexus on
feminism because you all arrived really
just when the women's movement is
starting to get going and so hi how did
your understanding of feminism change
over your time at Yale and I'm wondering
if the women's movement was something
that was important to you either when
you got here or by the time you left
okay at first I just want to say that
and just asked me would I be willing to
speak about sexual harassment and I said
I would but I'd rather speak about
feminism so I would but can I just say
something briefly about sexual
harassment I wish that I've said I don't
want to talk about it I was not actually
harassed by any people in authority
while I was here but I was assaulted one
summer when I was here for the doing
theater and it was summer Twilight and I
was a bunch of teenage boys came and
knocked me down and started undressing
me and it wasn't until I realized that I
needed to scream that they left as soon
as I screamed and then no one came and
so I redressed myself and went on to my
rehearsal
anyway that okay so I but I really want
to talk about feminism because I think
like like many of you this the first
year immediately upon arriving at Yale
there was a feeling of being woke
especially after the experiences of the
strike I mean even though that was
focused on other political issues
certainly feminism was there or feminist
issues were interwoven with with all of
what was happening during the strike and
I felt it very profoundly I would have
to say that my experiences
that year have become the foundation for
pretty much everything I've written
since which does not mean to it say that
any of what I've written since it has
been on biographical but I was very
interested at that time in androgyny and
my first play was about two women who
have ten androgynous children and send
them into the world and then they come
back and report their experiences and I
think that that play emerged from you
know now probably those kids would be
gender fluid or whatever but I think at
the time that was my personal reaction
to being in this experiment in this male
environment where to be ultra female I
didn't want to be ultra female but I
didn't want to be male either
and so as exploring and the interspecies
there and trying to figure out what that
meant I also want to say that I had a
very powerful mentorship with the the
playwright Adrienne Kennedy who was
having very having a lot of success in
the 60s the funny house of a Negro was
one of her well-known plays and she was
really helpful in getting helping me get
my plays produced in New York and there
was a kind of underlying understanding
on her part that women needed extra help
and I ed anyway I don't I never would
have hesitated even at the beginning
to say that I was a feminist and I have
felt that that never wavered I've been a
feminist ever since thanks guys
hey you want to speak to that sure I
have been reflecting including with the
other panels that we've listened to
about was I a feminist before I ever
came to Yale I certainly consider myself
one now and I think the answer is yes I
think it Springs out of just a belief
that we are all of equal value and
certainly I am and nobody pushes me
around and when I was about 12 I had a
rubber stamp made that said this ad
insults women and I would stamp these
Ladies Home Journal calls and mail it
off and the amazing thing I have to find
it because I think I saved it is I
actually got a letter from John Mac
Carter who said yeah you you're kind of
right but these ads are what pays for
our magazine and I wasn't going to take
that but I just think it's interesting
he took the time to write to a girl and
ironically years later there was a
feminist sit-in in his office so that
was quite interesting
I was lucky at Yale though to have a
number of wonderful women professors and
I was sort of surprised to hear that
some of you had none at all I just
wanted to recognize Anne Hanson in
history of art Ruth day she was
wonderful in psychology
Carolus Snyder I had for music theory
and she was a Wellesley woman as soon as
I left Wellesley I was convinced I was
meeting a remarkable Wellesley woman
everywhere I turned which would say well
why did you leave including Hillary
Clinton I had known it Wellesley because
she was a senior I was a freshman and
she was always in our dorm an amazing
woman I looked up to and then Ellen
Kenaston
also here in the law school I took a
great course about women and law I know
one of the teachers was Ann Hill I don't
remember the name of the other but it
was a terrific seminar so I felt very
nurtured and I think the the literature
that we were had already read but also
were exposed to before I came I know I
had read betty Friedan I think here's
Simone de Beauvoir Kate Millett actually
worked out of my father's radical church
in New York City in Washington Square
and then Susan Brown Miller now I I
still like feminists reading but I'm
going more towards humor because I think
there is humor in feminism a book I that
came out about two years ago I loved was
how to be a woman by a British writer
Caitlin Moran if you have a chance it's
very funny and will teach you how to be
a woman it's never too late and then
another thought I had I have always been
involved in the women's movement but I I
was envious of those among us who were
more vocal louder I really looked up to
them I also one time edging unto the
sexual harassment a TA who loved my
writing and would embarrass me having me
read it out loud my papers to the class
invited me to a party at his house and I
immediately thought he grades my papers
I can't go to his party and I told him
and I'm just amazed now with the I don't
know where that sense came from and so
still a feminist
[Applause]
forgive me we have just ten minutes left
and three questions and so I'm just
gonna to kind of give you a breath here
I am gonna just move on to the next
question and hopefully we'll have time
to pull the audience in but this is one
that has come up which is the the
question of sexual harassment you know
that that term sexual harassment was not
even coined yet no one even knew that
phrase when you all arrived here but
that doesn't mean that that as students
were immune to sexual harassment whether
by professors or graduate students or
other students on although when it
happened typically it was kept very
quiet so you may never have even known
it was going on even if it was with the
person someone you knew June you had
said you'd speak to this question do you
want to talk to so I'd like to speak
this question because all my life since
Yale I have regretted not speaking about
it something happened I kept it to
myself so I was freshman I'm bright I
died
I'm having this thrilling you know
intellectual experience at Yale and one
of my professors who I admired and has
since gone on to be a great in the world
he had assigned weekly papers and I was
getting A's on my papers which was
thrilling because I was worried like
everyone else that I was going to fail
out of Yale or you know I didn't know if
I was qualified or whatever so I won
about the third fourth week I get a
paper back and after getting A's this
one had a C and it had a note on it
saying C me so I made an appointment and
I went to his office I had to figure out
where was I'd never gone to a
professor's office and he started
talking to Mandy got up and he locked
the door to his office
and then he traced me around the room
and I was floored I was like what I was
like I wasn't scared I was just just
nonplussed I was like what you're my
professor what the hell are you doing
you know I was like I didn't get it and
I I looked I was like I just couldn't
believe it
anyway this this went on and finally I
just yelled at him and I said let me out
of here I'm just gonna scream just let
me out of here now I left okay so then I
didn't I told a couple of people just
because I was kind of traumatized so I
go back to class right my next weekly
paper and I came back with an F on it
and not only that it had a comment
saying this is the best paper you've
written all year so when that happened I
wasn't really worried because I had all
this evidence I mean what an idiot so I
just kept all the papers in a little
file
I wrote my next paper I think I got a D
or an F on every other paper finally it
comes to Bluebook day where you're
sitting to take your final for this
course and he's sit at the podium
addressing everyone about the the test
and before he left I got up out of my
seat and I went up to the podium with my
back to the audience here should there
were other students and I said excuse me
sir shall I take the test or you're just
gonna fail me and he looked at me and he
said take the test so I took the test
and that was it but and I think I I got
an A in the course or something in a
minus or something but it was like so
ridiculous and I've it I had thought I
should have done something because I
don't know if other people were going
through things like that but it was like
this kind of weird thing and the
professor had never had a student who
was a woman had never been in class with
a woman I think I was felt should I
wreck his career should I make this into
a big deal or is it he just as clueless
as I was you know I felt like we were
both kind of where
like I I was coming into a situation I
didn't understand and I think he was as
well but I've been conflicted really I
think about it all the time and with his
me to movement even more but I wonder if
other people had experiences like that
thank you for sharing that it's not
always easy to talk about we only have
five minutes left I'm so sorry this time
has just flown let me tell you the and I
apologize to the panelists because
they've prepared for some other
questions that we simply don't have time
for the but I want to share those with
you because I do hope you continue this
conversation one is on women who left so
I my stats are just on the freshmen
class because those were the from a
researchers point of view the cleanest
stats to look at but roughly 10% of the
women who started as freshmen here in
1969 did not chose to leave before
graduating from Yale which is it the
exact same percentages the men so given
all that you went through that's
actually pretty remarkable but I you
know and then a number of women and you
may have heard that today figured out
how to create some room from themselves
either by going on the five-year BA or
taking a term abroad or dropping out for
a semester and then coming back and so
that was one question you know did you
know anyone who left Yale and if so how
did that affect you or did you ever
consider leaving Yale yourself and then
the ninth question the closing question
what was the best or funniest or most
unexpected part about being at Yale so I
encourage you to ask one another that
this evening and what was the hardest or
the worst so anyway I said this was
mission impossible so many important
stories out there to hear and we have
just skimmed the surface but I I do want
to close not just by thanking this panel
but by thanking all of you and thanking
you
a woman who came after you thank you so
much for what you did for all of us
making it easier to be a woman at Yale
so when we close with a round of
applause for you and for our panel
[Applause]